in some of your films particularly the  Spanish language films you tend to set  in one setting and now at crimson peak  sort of as well and there's there's one  setting that's like a microcosm of the  world every some way everything is there  and monsters live in the bottom now well  the subterranean subterranean yeah and  and the other things live on the top but  I think everything-everything is a  microcosm oh I mean everything the small  and the big are the same and only thing  that that's a role in in in metaphysics  yeah but but but it's true is I feel  that for example in crimson peak for me  the house is ahead and in the humans  inside our element of thought and I  would say something else that is really  nice but it would ruin it but but but  but and even even the specters are  aspects of female possibilities and I  think in those terms you can articulate  something that that is a view of the  world but it is a view of the world  containing that in that movie